bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo accompagne
week-ends à metz bonjour michael vous
retrouver après deux semaines de break
parlementaire on va dire ça comme ça
dans l'actualité cette semaine il ya eu
la conférence de presse de françois
hollande bien sûr la deuxième de son
quinquennat
comment redonner de l'optimisme aux
français après les mauvais chiffres
annoncés sur la récession et le pouvoir
d'achat
c'était la difficile tâche du président
qui s'est dit à l'offensive pour cette 1
2 manuel valls dans le collimateur de
l'opposition le ministre de l'intérieur
se voit reprocher de ne pas avoir
anticipé les incidents du trocadéro lors
de la célébration du titre de champion
de france pour le paris saint-germain
le ministre le couple plus populaire du
gouvernement était la cible des
questions mardi dans l'hémicycle des
députés ump ont même réclamé sa
démission
enfin on va parler cinéma à la fin de
cette émission avec la sortie du pouvoir
un documentaire réalisé par patrick
rotman sur la première année de françois
hollande à l'elysée le président a
laissé la caméra s'attarder sur son
quotidien dans ce palais de la
république hors du temps et avec ses
rituels suranné selon les mots du
réalisateur est avec nous tout au long
de cette émission reggae nos bonjour
bonjour depuis été ump des yvelines
ancien conseiller de nicolas sarkozy on
vous présente plus à vous connaissez la
formule de cette émission on a demandé
aux parlementaires leur petit mot pour
savoir ce qu'il pensait de vous tout
simplement et pierre on va revenir pour
proposer aussi d'autres questions
d'actualité qui vous concerne en tout
cas ces derniers jours
mais d'abord on écoute les
parlementaires au micro de valérie
brochard nous avons des liens d'amitié
qui sont très forts
j'ai beaucoup d'affection d'amitié de
respect pour lui neuf cas sur dix un peu
moins deux fois sur trois je suis en
désaccord avec lui et souvent et
franchement désaccord mais
il fait partie me semble-t-il de ces
parlementaires qui donne aussi un
certain contenu à la vie politique et
c'est quelqu'un qui a l'expérience et
évidemment du back office qui sait ce
que c'est que le pouvoir qui découvre
aussi sans doute d'une certaine façon la
vie parlementaire et j'imagine pour lui
que c'est pas si simple que ça moi
j'aime bien henri guaino quand
celle henri guaino qui réfléchit à long
terme
c'est une dimension qui manque à
l'action politique aujourd'hui que se
projeter dans le temps qui vient et
parce que on regarde dans le temps passé
dans dans l'histoire les enseignements à
en tirer
lhenry guaino qui prend des positions
extrêmement trancher sur l'actualité je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le meilleur du
henri guaino et celui qu'on apprécie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez un peu de
recul donc on vous préfère quand vous
prenez votre plume par exemple quand
vous avez cette touche un peu romanesque
un peu inhabituel en politique
oui là il parlait pas vraiment non par
l'ehpad romanès qui parlait de parler de
perspectives de long terme
moi je crois qu'il faut il faut être sur
tous les registres
il ya le rejet du long terme qui est
évidemment essentiel moi je me suis
toujours efforcé de réfléchir au long
terme
on peut être d'accord ou pas avec mes
réflexions mais lorsque c'est
indispensable aujourd'hui pour la
politique de se projeter en avant puis
il ya aussi l'actualité le court terme
des prises de positions sur ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en ce moment et qu'est
ce que vous préférez faire
on est les deux simplement ce que l'on
fait dans le les médias tu es comme vous
dites doit s'inscrire dans une vision de
long terme dans une démarche de long
terme
moi je ne je ne je ne fais rien qui soit
juste dans la réaction jeu j'essaye bien
ou mal peut-être maladroitement parfois
mais j'essaye de d'inclure tout ce que
je fais tout ce que je dis dans une
vision de long terme dans une cohérence
qui met qui m'est propre
je pense que c'est la seule façon de
aujourd'hui de faire de la politique
sinon on est emporté par le le flot de
l'information en continu il n'en reste
rien alors dans l'immédiateté là
justement vous êtes entré en rébellion
contre contrôler les juges pour ceux qui
auront raté l'épisode précédent on va on
va y revenir
vous avez dit du juge gentil et qui a
mis nicolas sarkozy en examen qu'il
déshonorait la justice dans la foulée et
à une plainte contre vous pour outrage à
magistrat ou dénonciation une
dénonciation c'est une initiation de
l'union syndicale des magistrats
c'était dans leur lettre
monsieur le procureur nous dénonçons
alors guaino vous avez réussi un tour de
force d'entraîner derrière vous 107
députés
alors à l'heure actuelle c'est ça ou je
pense pas qu'ils ont cosigné une lettre
ouverte aux procureurs pour dire qu'ils
vous soutenons pour dire qu'il reprenait
mes propos ils vont rappeler aux
procureurs des grands principes de la
république
et pour dire que dans cet esprit de
défense des grands principes de la
république
il reprenait mes propos et il les assume
et il en assumer les éventuelles
conséquences j'espère vous des
laissez-passer d'intimider la justice
pour le parti socialiste aux portes
savez cette histoire d'abord c'est pas
de l'immédiateté s'inscrit pour moi dans
un combat de très long terme de très
longue durée sur une certaine idée de
l'art et pour une certaine idée de la
république qui aujourd'hui bien abîmée
voilà c'est ma conception de la
république qui l'a conduit à la
séparation des pouvoirs qui peuvent
travailler librement si vous m'avez pas
empêché juge de travailler librement
vous avez vu les parlementaires déposer
des projets de loi pour empêcher le juge
gentil d'aller au bout de sa procédure
non là il s'agit pas de save comprenez
d'un séparation des pouvoirs d'abord ça
ne peut pas être à sens unique
la séparation des pouvoirs c'est pas
d'un côté les juges qui peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent et à tenter des
procédures aux parlementaires pour leur
pour leurs propos dans le débat public
et puis de l'autre côté des
parlementaires qui ne dit jamais rien
qui se laissent traîner là pouvoir
parler librement c'est bien ça je pense
que ça c'est ça c'est la règle absolue
de la démocratie c'est peut-être devoir
d'exemplarité 0 ça vous pouvez vous
refusez de vous dire que ça va avec
l'exemplarité comme une chose une chose
sinon on n'y comprend rien d'abord je
jeudi
j'affirme je proclame que dans une
société libre dans une démocratie dans
une république il n'y a pas de délit
d'opinion ce que j'ai exprimée est une
opinion dont je ne peux pas être
poursuivi pour une opinion si on
demande d'aller devant un tribunal
j'irai devant un tribunal et je dirais
exactement cela et je le dirai avec les
107 collègues qui ont dit la même chose
et je pense que dans leur for intérieur
beaucoup de mes collègues socialistes de
marge en cours des collègues centristes
ont la même conviction que moi selon le
devoir d'exemplarité mérité de voir les
dix ans que des exemples mais je donne
l'exemple je défends l'idée de la
république et quand vous dites que vous
ne répondrai pas une convocation comme
les indiens scène l'exemplarité bien sûr
mais bien sûr cette plaisanterie tc le
respect de la loi
c'est le respect de la constitution
l'article 26 de la constitution dit que
nul membres du parlement ne peut être ni
poursuivis ni inquiétés pour les
opinions exprimées dans le cadre de
l'exercice de son mandat ou de son vote
jeu
je considère qu'aujourd'hui et ses deux
cabinets 107 collègues et de beaucoup de
membres de l'assemblée
ça ne se limite pas le mandat de député
ne se disent pas que dans l'hémicycle
nous sommes dans la société de
l'information
moi je suis pas invité par vous
aujourd'hui ni par europol ni par bfm tv
m
je suis pas invitée comme intermittent
du spectacle je suis invité qu'on me
députés nous sommes bien d'accord nous a
mis devant vous le député des yvelines
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
m'invitez je parle en tant que
parlementaire et je revendique pour le
citoyen et a fortiori pour le
parlementaire le droit d'intervenir dans
le débat public pour porter des
jugements sur la manière dont les agents
publics remplissent leur fonction
le juge est un agent public ça c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme du
citoyen article 15 articles de 15 ans et
tout agent public doit rendre des
comptes
il peut pas y avoir une profession qui
soit à l'abri des critiques à l'abri des
jugement moral de ses concitoyens et a
fortiori de leurs représentants j'ai
porté le membre pourquoi je ne vais pas
pourquoi je ne vais pas je ne veux pas
me rendre aussi bien sûr mais si oui
mais c'est très important parce que vous
avez à la crise actuelle et elle est
faite de beaucoup de sujets qui
s'emboîtent les uns dans les autres la
crise de la république qui est très
profonde
pourquoi je je je souhaite ne pas aller
ne pas me rendre
la convocation d'un compte d'abord on
ouvre une enquête préliminaire bon
pourquoi une enquête mais propose son
public
mes propos sont assumés mes propos sont
clairs ils ont été tenus en direct et
répété dix fois pas donc il n'y a pas de
jeu pas besoin de chercher autre chose
deuxième deuxièmement quand même ça a
été confiée à la brigade de répression
de la brigade de répression de la
délinquance sur la personne n'ose
imaginer quand même que police apporte
chose à faire il ya pas de délinquants
dans la rue 1 dont il faut s'occuper
troisièmement bien c'est très simple
moi je suis prêt à répondre à toutes à
toutes les convocations dans le cadre
des procédures prévues dans l'article 26
de la constitution c'est-à-dire que si
on veut marquer mais je ne suis pas
obligé si on veut me obligé et bien on
ne saisit de bureau de l'assemblée
nationale
et puis moi je peux ensuite saisir
l'assemblée nationale elle même pour se
pendre des poursuites et puis s'il n'y a
pas de suspension de poursuites si le
luron l'assemblée l'interview d'habilité
je dirais que vous ou la mission si vous
allez messieurs se faisant parfaitement
la loi la constitution et la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen et
que nous avons besoin d'un vrai débat on
l'a vu avec le mur des cons nous avons
besoin d'un vrai débat pour définir les
droits et les devoirs de chacun
mais les dérives actuelles ne sont pas
acceptables voilà je le dis en tant que
député chrétien s'est passé à l'analyse
de la semaine sereinement oui lundi on
parle retraite à matignon
c'est une réunion préparatoire la
conférence sociale qui aura lieu les 20
et 21 juin prochains
les syndicats sont reçus par jean marc
ayrault en ce lundi et c'est le lourd
dossier des retraites ce qui prédomine
chacun expose ses revendications et sans
surprise elle ne convergent pas elisa
berthelot mais officiellement ces
réunions servent à préparer la
conférence sociale de juin prochain
officieusement syndicats et gouvernement
discute déjà des grandes lignes de la
prochaine réforme des retraites à peine
celle de nicolas sarkozy instaurer une
autre réforme va devoir voir le jour car
il ya urgence à l'horizon 2020 le
système des retraites français aura
besoin d'un financement de 20 milliards
d'euros
déjà les syndicats font des propositions
notre préconisations et d'allonger la
durée de cotisation à 43 ans d'ici 2020
et par ailleurs de repousser l'âge légal
de la retraite à au moins 65 ans à
l'horizon 2040
des propositions qui font réagir les
autres syndicats si force ouvrière et la
cgt s'oppose à tout rallongement la cfdt
est plus conciliante
la cfdt a toujours dit que entre du rush
de départ et durée de cotisation
le paramètre le plus juste et et la
durée de cotisation ça ne veut pas dire
qu'à l'heure qu'il est à l'heure où je
vous parle la cfdt est pris position sur
telle ou telle proposition qui n'est pas
encore sur la table pour le gouvernement
deux solutions sont pour l'instant
l'étude d'un côté limité la
revalorisation des pensions de l'autre
relever les cotisations ou les
prélèvements à la conférence sociale
nous aurons sur la table toutes les
options possibles qui pourront faire
l'objet d' échange approfondi puis
s'engagera le temps nécessaire la
discussion avec les partenaires sociaux
les consultations sur ce sujet se
tiendront cet été un projet de loi sera
discutée au parlement dès l'automne
henri guaino on devra travailler plus
longtemps a dit jeudi françois hollande
tout ça paraît inévitable allonger la
durée de cotisation plus tôt reculer
l'âge légal de retraite donc les deux
sans doute jeu
mais travailler plus longtemps
travailler plus longtemps à cause de la
démographie cause du fait qu'on vit plus
longtemps
puis aussi parce que le chômage fait que
tant qu'on aura un système qui sera
financé exclusivement par le travail est
bien le chômage réduira les recettes
donc il faut il faut changer notre mode
de financement il faut combattre
évidemment chômage qui nous renvoie le
débat sur la crise et enfin tenir compte
de la démographie mais moi je n'entre
allonger la durée à travailler davantage
ou baisser le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités diminuer les pensions de
retraite
mon choix moi il est très clair c'est
travailler plus je trouve que la pire
des solutions
c'est de diminuer le pouvoir d'achat des
retraites
tout cela va se faire dans la
concertation lors d'une conférence
sociale au mois de juin
est ce que c'est la bonne méthode pour
éviter la rue comme vous avez pu
l'affronter en 2010 par exemple
non parce que tout le monde sera sera
pas d'accord et que et beaucoup de gens
exprimeront leur deuil
lors des accords c'est normal c'est
parce qu'il y en aura c'est normal je
vois pas comment on va arriver à mettre
d'accord la cgt la cfdt force ouvrière
en sandales r2 pourtant il trouvera
d'accord il a pris l'exemple de l'accord
national sur le sur le travail là quand
ça sur le travail là ni la cgt ni force
ouvrière n'était partie prenante à cet
accord et sans parler des syndicats dits
non représentatifs y sont quand même
important comme sud et c'est donc non on
mettra tout le monde d'accord c'est
normal ce sont des réformes difficiles
sont dès 2010 c'est ce qu'a posteriori
vous regrettez de ne pas avoir fait plus
loin plus fort les jacinthes et peuvent
même pas du tout parce que comme vous
l'avez dit très clairement le président
sarkozy l'époque d'abord il faut faire
les choses
c'est mieux de faire progresser des
réformes progressives mais qui sont
acceptées pas parler français même
difficilement mais accepter quand même
plutôt que d'essayer de faire d'un coup
une réforme définitive qui ne
passeraient pas parce que c'était un
effort trop grand bain d'un seul coup il
a il l'a dit d'ailleurs il ya pas dans
ce domaine ira jamais de réforme
définitive il faut accompagner
l'évolution de la démographie et
l'évolution de l'économie
vous ne pouvez pas faire autrement et
donc il faut être progressif
origine on va passer au mardi la fête
gâchée du paris saint germain se déplace
sur le terrain politique
manuel valls est sous le feu des
critiques après la soirée de violence au
trocadéro mauvaise anticipation manque
de moyens policiers même laxisme supposé
l'opposition pointe la responsabilité du
ministre comme nous l'expliquent paul
bouffard c'est un ministre dans l'oeil
du cyclone après les débordements du
trocadéro la droite sénatoriale reproche
à manuel valls de ne pas avoir la
carrure de premier flic de france monte
à l'aune des soins tout le monde quand
on veut singer nicolas sarkozy il faut
bien le faire
or visiblement stamm les imitateurs
quand quelqu'un tous les jours dit qu'il
est le plus fort qu'il est le meilleur
et qu'il ya un événement comme ça qui se
passe c'est que ce qu'il dit n'est pas
tout à fait vrai pourtant les ténors ump
réfute toute récupération politique
ces sujets sont trop graves pour faire
de la politique politicienne ne comptait
pas sur moi pour stigmatiser telle ou
telle personnalité
est-ce que la récupération politique et
pas de facile e est ce que je viens de
la sphère politique avec je crois pas
manuel valls un ministre clé dans le
dispositif gouvernemental la majorité
présidentielle fait corps et s'insurge
contre cette charge
enfin presque c'est une responsabilité
du club ou de groupes du ministère de
l'intérieur qui aurait dû être pas donné
d'autorisation ont peut-être des deux
peut-être dès le je pense qu'il aurait
mieux valu faire ça au parc des princes
dans un stade fermé pour éviter aux
casseurs de de pénétrer ce soir place
beauvau le ministre avait convoqué les
acteurs de l'événement et notamment les
dirigeants du paris saint germain
alors selon le ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls qui l'a dit dans
l'hémicycle il paraît que l'ordre
auraient changé de camp vous êtes
d'accord
non c'est une plaisanterie c'est parce
que tout le monde tout le monde qu'il y
ait de l'ordre
hammouche épanouie de désordre je suis
un homme d'ordre sans oublier le
mouvement j'ai vu que hier le pr de
président et public il parle beaucoup du
mouvement et pas de l'ordre jeu mais il
faut les deux vous savez l'ordre sans le
mouvement c'est mortifère et le
mouvement sans l'ordre c'est suicidaire
non quant au maintien de l'ordre j'ai vu
contre déployé des forces et 50 pour
encadrer des manifestations de famille
pacifique
qu'en revanche les forces de l'ordre
n'étaient pas là pour encadrer les dés
pour empêcher les casseurs de casser
l'autre jour sur la place du trocadéro
sa blessure les casseurs ou même dans
les andes est d'accord il opérait manuel
valls ecoutez-la l'opposition a demandé
le père particulier à l'international
une commission d enquête donc on va vers
une commission d enquête et on verra
quelles fautes ont été commises à je
pense que les choses sont simples moi
j'attends le résultat de cette commune
ans pour penser qu'il veut récupération
politique c'était la question du sujet
qu'on vient de voir un instant entendu
notamment jean-claude collègues et dit
non pas de récupération petit pourtant
on a quand même la pression a coûté
apprécier son travail il ya mais à
l'intérieur elles rient désordre il ya
des cas des victimes il ya des violences
attaques commises à l'intérieur des
partis du de des normes habituelles
habitudes d'un régime parlementaire et
repositionne majoritaire le gouvernement
fait son travail c'est sa passion a fait
son travail
maintenant je vais dire comme jean
claude gaudin vous m'avez entendue dans
la récupération politique faite bien
voilà donc il ya une commission denquête
on verra si des fautes ont été commises
je pense que tout n'a pas été fait quand
même avec le plus grand sérieux dans
cette affaire mais alors environ on va
rester finalement sur la question des
casseurs lors des manifestations puisque
mardi encore il y avait un texte bien
embarrassant pour les socialistes
l'amnistié social une proposition de loi
communiste déjà voté au sénat et qui
prévoit donc d'amnistié certains délits
commis lors des mouvements sociaux
le gouvernement est contre mais certains
députés socialistes cette semaine
s'était prononcé peau
alors on ce mardi les députés annoncent
qu'ils vont renvoyer le texte en
commission alors qu'il devait être
examinée ce jeudi
l'explication d'arabica amnistie les
syndicats pour des délits commis lors de
mouvements sociaux une proposition de
loi communiste adopté au sénat par une
très courte majorité le 27 février
dernier un vote à l'époque salué par la
garde des sceaux je crois que le sénat
aujourd'hui a vraiment accompli un acte
de très grande qualité de très grande
justice un acte qui honore la république
et le gouvernement
quelques mois plus tard changement de
discours le texte arrive à l'assemblée
le gouvernement marque son opposition à
l'aministie sociale le gouvernement
n'est pas favorable au principe de la
loi d'amnistié parce que il considère
que dans la situation qui vient d'être
évoquée d'ailleurs que la france vit
aujourd'hui il doit y avoir qu'une seule
réponse qui est au coeur de la
république c'est le respect de la loi
républicaine
un coup dur pour le front de gauche
andré chassaigne dénonce un manque de
courage de la part du gouvernement
moi je trouve que le loup le renard
donne un signe le signal d'un moment qui
capitule devant les exigences développé
par le medef
mais c'est au sein même de la majorité
que cette proposition divise
plusieurs députés socialistes
soutiennent cette proposition de loi ne
faut pas criminaliser l'action syndicale
dans ce pays
et que cette loi d'amis si elle est
aussi un signe d'apaisement
elles étaient eux
estime que
on peut comprendre
non pas qu'ils aient dégradation des
atteintes à la personne humaine
mettez les moments de colère quand on a
tout perdu son boulot
l'entreprise et même l'adhésion justice
qui pouvait à la fin vous sauver un peu
le groupe socialiste a demandé que le
texte soit renvoyée en commission des
lois les députés examineront cette
motion de renvoi ce jeudi et ce jeudi
effectivement les députés ont voté une
motion de renvoi en commission malgré
les protestations des communistes c'est
un texte que le gouvernement ne pouvait
pas se permettre de voter la d'abord il
semble que si j'en crois monsieur
mélenchon que monsieur hollande lui
avait promis cette amnistie donc fait
toujours le prix de ses mensonges
visuellement j'ai entendu madame le
garde des sceaux mais cela voudrait-il
dire que les les jugements rendus de
telles mauvaises décisions qu'ils
devraient être ainsi désavoué ils
s'accordent enfin oui mais c'est
intéressant ce jeu et enfin on peut pas
l'ami si ça existe ça a toujours existé
on à présent sarkozy n'a pas fait la
passe ou été arrêté le 3 mai mais ça
concernait à l'époque plusieurs
catégories visées ainsi une seule
catégorie pensait qu'à une seule
catégorie de casseurs légitime quand
même un problème
1 pourquoi le casseur syndicaliste
serait plus légitime que le casseur delà
du trocadéro la manif pour tous on est
d'accord marge de la manifestation je
suis d'accord mais vous remarquerez
quand même que le damany forte hausse
n'a pas laissé le champ de ruines
fumantes quelques débordements aucune
vitrine cassée aucune voiture brûlée il
ya ma connaissance aucun blessé donc
c'est pas comparable se dit rien et
compass mais un voyou est un voyou un
casseur est un casseur imaginer que là
on amnistie les casseurs et pas les
petites contravention de gourmands c'est
plutôt bien
le fait qu'il ait pas eu cette loi
d'aministie pour moi en tout cas oui je
le pense je pense que c'est ou et je
pense que c'est mieux c'était un très
mauvais signal tout de même donner
donner aux français ce qui est carrément
banias non non je pense que ça peut ça
peut être utile parfois je dis pas dire
que les amis ce type de temps passe et
ne servent à rien elle désengorger un
peu le système mais reçoit là vous le
faites pour tout le monde et pour les
pour les petites peines vous ne
récompenser pas d'un verre qu'on nous
prend exclure les casseurs pourrait
concerner
pensez pas ce qui casse le bien des
autres fois ce week-end je vous propose
de parler un petit peu de l'ump sawicki
un accord de paix qui a été signé en
tout cas cette semaine entre françois
fillon et jean françois copé se sont
accordés pour réformer les statuts du
parti ils seront soumis au vote des
militants en juin prochain lors d'un
congrès il y aura bien des primaires en
tout cas pas de l'élection
présidentielle le détail avec germain
andrieu jean françois copé et françois
fillon côte à côte
cinq mois après la crise de l'ump les
deux rivaux ont trouvé un accord pour de
nouveaux statuts vont nous sommes mis
d'accord effectivement sur de nouveaux
statuts ont maintenant les soumettre au
vote des militants naturellement et ça
s'est passé dans un climat qui est
extrêmement constructifs positifs
il va maintenant falloir mettre en
oeuvre ses statuts composer une haute
autorité et nous allons avancer vers un
dispositif qui sera transparent et
démocratique
reste à trancher la question d'un
nouveau vote en septembre pour la
présidence de l'ump
rien n'est encore officiel mais pour les
copéiste et les fillonnistes ce nouveau
vote n'est finalement plus du tout une
priorité
vous savez c'est comme cette caricature
de l' affaire dreyfus où il ya des gens
qui sont à table tout se passe bien ils
n'en ont pas parlé
et puis après il ya les couteaux qui
sont sortis ils en ont parlé pour
l'instant on n'a pas parlé voilà moi
vous connaissez ma position je considère
que faire une élection maintenant avant
les municipales au moment où on a une
telle crise économique c'est pas le
moment
probablement nous n'aurons pas
d'élections de toute façon nous avons un
référendum sur les statuts mon
opposition personnelle c'est que ce sont
les militants qui peuvent prendre
position donc à l'occasion du référendum
sur les statuts moi je serais favorable
personnellement mais nous n'avons pas
encore discuté je serais favorable à ce
qu'il y ait un référendum sur le vote
les militants majoritairement contre une
nouvelle élection devrait choisir avant
l'été lors d'un référendum où ils se
prononceront aussi sur les nouveaux
statuts
l'ump devrait officialiser cette
procédure lors de son prochain bureau
politique la semaine prochaine alors
henri guaino vous les primaires pour
l'élection présidentielle s'est pas
vraiment votre tasse de thé c'est pas
très gaulliste
d'abord une sauce est pas un accord
entre jean françois copé françois fillon
la commission des statuts comporter des
dizaines de membres
les personnalités du mouvement était là
voilà c'est en se tenant pour chacun
fait débat des pas vers les autres
même quand on n'est pas d'accord sur
tout ce qui est mon cas d'accord non
plus c'est pas c'est pas une copropriété
l'ump voilà et dense est dans cette
commission des statuts c'était encore
moins une copropriété que je te laisse
penser vos images super pour l'élection
présidentielle
vous êtes pour vous êtes content moi je
suis con voir un petit peu plus tard je
suis contre ce principe maintenant comme
toi si tout le monde en veut si la
majorité des adhérents vote pour les
primaires il y aura il y aura des
primaires enfin vous savez comme comme
comme l'histoire nous l'enseignent la
politique elle se fait en fonction des
circonstances alors que ses intentions
mais quoi il ya des statuts il y avait
dit lui même puis nous verrons mais pour
de faux rapports de force politiques il
ya réellement des primaires savez-vous
nature de quelque chose vous sur
l'avenir voilà effectivement oui mais ça
dépendra de ce qui va se passer par
exemple si tu colas sarkozy romain voilà
bon alors il faudra repasser par des
primaires je suis face à voir ce qu'en
dit la magie n'est pas un instant que
les choses se passent de cette manière
parce que tout simplement il a été le
président de tous les français vous
l'imaginez revenir faire de la politique
à l'intérieur de son camp avant de
retourner vers la mer des français si
les nordistes ont cela mais ils
s'appuient vous aurez des ans pèse
personne d'être candidat la présence à
l'appui d'accord mais un statut oblige
peut-être de faire une élection
l'exilé pas aidé pas quand devient
dépendant de la commission des statuts
s'il revient c'est parce que les
circonstances l'appellerons parce que le
pays il appellera parce que la situation
l'exigera et voilà les choses si jamais
il ya des primaires ce moment là ce sera
une formalité mais je n'imagine pas
nicolas sarkozy à l'ensemble sera
enfermé dans son camp pour ensuite
revenir devant tous les français ce qui
est probable d'ailleurs des primaires
c'est que elle sélectionne le candidat
du camp regardez ce qui s'est passé on
dire prends un exemple socialiste à bord
des comptes en a élu le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste il est
toujours premier secrétaire du parti
socialise est pas tellement président de
la république le pire président depuis
le début de la cinquième
juste avant la drogue et on parle de
nicolas sarkozy votre sentiment
aujourd'hui difficile de voir dans
l'avenir de votre sentiment fait lequel
il va revenir je n'en sais rien nous
verrons selon des circonstances lançons
en 10 secondes et il fera son devoir ça
dépendra de ce que de ce que la
situation exige
je crois que c'est tout c'est aussi ça a
évidemment envie de refaire de la
politique comme avant mais maintenant 6
6 et 6 pensent que c'est son devoir de
revenir hier soir là il reviendra mais
nous verrons personne ne sait ce que
l'avenir nous vous parle comme pour les
candidats mais moi je ne prévois rien je
n'envisage rien et je n'exclus rien
éventuellement vous à vous auriez aimé
être candidat à la présidence de l'ump
un staff à autre chose et peut-être est
verrouillé actuellement ça vous
intéresse toujours puisqu'il y aura un
nouveau président une nouvelle élection
présidence présidentielle donc on verra
moi je aujourd'hui vous savez les
français s'en moque il ya une crise elle
est terrible six mois là c'est pas mon
problème au prince et la crise mais nous
verrons le moment venu il sera temps de
s'occuper de ces questions de ces
questions électorales pour l'instant
occupons nous des problèmes des français
mon amie on a arrêté nos déchirures
restons-en là qui fournit des pensées
voyez nos mercredi c'est confirmé la
france est bien en récession les
économies sont une règle il faut deux
trimestres sans croissance pour que l'on
puisse dire qu'un pays est en récession
en ce mercredi c'est fait la france a
connu un recul de son produit intérieur
brut de 0 2% au premier trimestre 2013
après une baisse similaire au dernier
trimestre 2012
le gouvernement veut rester optimiste
pour la suite et lisa berthelot mais on
ne peut pas qualifié cette annonce de
surprises avec deux trimestres
consécutifs de baisse la france est
officiellement en récession au premier
trimestre 2013 le pib a reculé de 0,2
pour cent pourtant pas question pour le
gouvernement de revoir ses prévisions à
la baisse
je maintiens à la fois les chiffres les
perspectives de croissance pour 2013 0
1% ce qui est possible et aussi
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
d'ici la fin de 2013
en mobilisant l'économie française autre
mauvaise nouvelle la consommation des
ménages est atone l'insee observe aussi
un repli des investissements
face à cette situation difficile jean
françois copé met directement en cause
le chef de l'état les mesures qui ont
été prises depuis un an par françois
hollande me conduisent à considérer que
le président de la république porte sa
part de responsabilité personnelle dans
l'aggravation de la situation économique
de notre pays
réaction également à l'assemblée si la
majorité continue de défendre le
gouvernement
l'opposition pointe un manque de
crédibilité le gouvernement y maintient
ses prévisions comme toujours ça ne veut
plus rien dire d'ailleurs plus personne
ne croit vraiment la parole du
gouvernement pour tout vous dire c'est
pas parce que
on a cette nouvelle là ce matin qu'il
faut baisser les bras la france va s'en
sortir
la crise ne sera pas éternelle c'est à
nous d'engager cette bataille une
annonce qui tombe mal alors que françois
hollande est à bruxelles aujourd'hui
mais une annonce nuancée par les
économistes eux mêmes selon eux malgré
ce recul l'économie française devrait
connaître une croissance de 0,1 pour
cent au deuxième trimestre 2013
perspectives de croissance donc 0 1%
pour 2013
il faut rester optimiste c'est peut-être
le non non non non il n'y a pas de
raison d'être optimiste ni optimiste ni
pessimiste faut regarder les choses
telles qu'elles sont
c'est quand même c'est sinistrement
drôle dire vos seins france est
officiellement en récession la france et
d'europe sont en accession depuis des
mois tout le monde le sait on a
maintenant la confirmation statistiques
mais d'ailleurs la science était bien
plus grave que ne le montrent que
statistiques quand on sait comment ces
mesures et et voilà on est dans une
situation dramatique toute l'économie
s'effondre elle s'effondre en france
elle s'effondre dans une bonne partie de
l'europe
que fait-on face à ce désastre la
première mesure urgente à faire là tout
de suite c'est pas une mesure et c'est
pas humain c'est d'abord on allait voir
ses partenaires européens dire ça peut
pas continuer comme ça on peut pas
cumuler en europe de seul endroit au
monde où on cumule politique monétaire
trop restrictive encore politique
budgétaire restrictive politique fiscale
restrictive
ça n'est pas possible quand vous êtes en
récession vous ne faites pas des
politiques de ce genre parce que
l'europe va finir par devenir nilo de
déflation dans un monde d'inflation
regarder ce qu'on fait au japon aux
états unis en grande bretagne et voilà
l'europe court un risque mortel
c'est parce qu'elle est en droit comme
prévu à l'avancé sur le déclin
aujourd'hui pour s'acharner sur le
déclin est en crise oui ça c'est une
crise très très grave
un pouvoir d'achat il est en baisse
depuis longtemps les cancans les
chiffres montrent la baisse est encore
pire parce qu'en réalité il ya des
situations très très différente aussi la
moyenne est en baisse vous imaginez ce
que ça représente pour la plupart des
français bon donc on est on est dans une
situation d'une gravité exceptionnelle
au bonnet en non seulement récession
bien au bord de la dépression et de la
déflation c'est-à-dire au bord d'une
situation qui ressemble pourrait
ressembler très vite à celle des années
alors il faut en avoir conscience ne
change pas de position sur la rigueur
est ce qu'il est possible de faire
quelque chose d'observer la position ça
change pas comme ça ça change parce
qu'on se bat pour la faire changer
oui oui je suis pas sûr qu'ils se soient
battus de la meilleure façon qui soit
c'est pas non plus en cultivant
l'inimitié franco-allemande qu'on fait
changer les allemands de position et
puis derrière il ya un problème
démographique en allemagne qui thiam qui
imprime une politique à l'allemagne une
politique particulière donc
ah oui laurent pas des problèmes
aujourd'hui elle a des difficultés mais
c'est parce que nous a proposé le
président de la république hier qui va
nous permettre de sortir ni
nationalement ni sur le plan européen de
ces difficultés qui nous met dans un
piège extrêmement table il va parler de
la conférence de presse de françois
hollande nous y venons nous sommes jeudi
plus de deux heures trente de conférence
de presse pour le président de la
république à ton offensif volontariste
même diront certains ses priorités la
lutte contre le chômage et l'union
politique européenne voilà pour le
programme de l'an 2 pour françois
hollande le détail avec elisa bartholomé
offensive le mot clé de cette conférence
de presse de françois hollande et
offensive sur l'europe
le chef de l'état prend acte du délai
supplémentaire accordé par la commission
européenne pour réduire le déficit du
pays
pour moi ce délai deux ans pour la
france ce n'est pas un répit c'est un
rebond c'est une opportunité pour une
reprise plus rapide en france et en
europe
une reprise que françois hollande veut
soutenir au niveau européen grâce à un
arsenal de mesures qu'il compte faire
adopter dans les deux ans notamment
l'instauration d'un gouvernement
économique ou la création d'une
communauté européenne de l'énergie
objectif sortir de la crise et faire
reculer le chômage dès cette année je
réédite ici devant vous en prenant mes
risques mais aussi mes responsabilités
que la courbe du chômage peut s'inverser
d'ici la fin de l'année
lutter contre le chômage grâce à un
catalogue de nouvelles mesures
notamment un plan d'investissement
présenté dès le mois de juin ou encore
une réorientation de l'épargné pour
financer les entreprises
autres mesures fortes annoncées la
réforme du système des retraites
mais dès lors que l'espérance de vie
s'allonge il ya un principe qui est
celui de l'évidence dès lors que l'on
vit plus longtemps parfois beaucoup plus
longtemps
on devra travailler aussi un peu plus
côté sociétal le chef de l'état est
revenu sur le droit de vote des
étrangers
une réforme décalé à 2014 ce texte ne
sera pas présentée jusqu aux élections
municipales et après les élections
municipales comme ça il n'y aura pas
d'enjeu il sera soumis au parlement et
le parlement en fera l'adoption s'ils le
souhaitent
et s'il n'y a pas la majorité des 3 5e
est bien le constat sera établi un
françois hollande combatif qui a
réaffirmé son soutien à jean marc
ayrault et au gouvernement mais pas
facile pour le chef de l'état de tenir
son cap
je suis président au pire moment at il
déclaré alors voilà en tout cas pour le
détail des annonces du président de la
république sur parce que nicolas sarkozy
ce n'est pas le pire moment bien sûr
marié robinet mais je voudrais entendre
aussi sur la forme le mot offensif
prononcé 12 fois le mot mouvement aussi
qui est revenu de nombreux sauvetages
justement l'impression d'entendre un
petit peu nicolas sarkozy ne prononçait
pas le montant 600 ha il était offensif
et prenez la crise à bras le corps pas
vu encore monsieur hollande prend
vraiment la crise à bras le corps et
puis vous savez c'est bien on va faire
un plan d'investissement peut que s'en
réjouir mais s'il avait pas ça aurait
été plus crédible s'il n'avait pas
commencé prendre au début de son
quinquennat par couper tous les grands
programmes d'investissement bon les
retraites il ya phare travaillent plus
longtemps ce serait plus crédible aussi
s'il n'avait pas répété pendant la
réforme des retraite de nicolas sarkozy
c'était scandaleux d'allonger la durée
de
du revenu en arrière durée du travail
n'est parvenue en a un petit peu quand
même quelques milliards mais non mais
non pas ceux carrière pénible est revenu
en a sur les carrières longues années
sur quelques-unes des carrières longues
mais c'est quand même extraordinaire
décalage qui entre ce qui a été dit
pendant quatre ans cinq ans nicolas
sarkozy était au pouvoir
puis ce qui a été fait au début du
quinquennat et ce qui mène ce que ce
qu'il veut faire maintenant a estimé qu'
il ya eu un temps où finalement il a été
un petit peu en apprentissage à pato et
qu'il revient aujourd'hui son concept
pendant un an ont pris la ville à verser
non il a essentiellement passé son temps
à défaire ce que nicolas sarkozy avait
fait bon donc aujourd'hui fait quoi
alors ben il essaie maladroitement de
refaire certaines dé reprendre certaines
des mesures que nicolas sarkozy avait
mais en a je pense que le président
nicolas sarkozy je me trompe camou non
parce que dans ce port gentil pour
nicolas sarkozy je trouve que la
comparaison
comparaison n'est pas bonne qui dit
investissement qui dit relance puisque
vous pensez que cette solution guidée
pour 110 dépenses on est d'accord à ce
qu'on a les moyens
ces dépenses l'invasion mais on a vu le
jour vous n'investissez plus défini vous
êtes mort pour l'avenir 1 vous
remboursez vos dettes etc avec les
revenus de demain et revenez demain
c'est les investissements d'aujourd'hui
de la question se pose même pas de toute
façon il faut investir
de toute façon il faut investir
massivement parce qu'on est à l'orée
d'un nouveau cycle de croissance au
nouveau modèle de croissance sinon vous
fait il va vous arriver est arrivé ce
qui est arrivé aux pays qui ont raté
l'entrée dans la notion industriels ou
des trente glorieuses
vous ne rattraperait jamais le temps
perdu mais on le fait avec une hausse
des impôts en moyenne contre la hausse
des impôts
je pense que pour pour investir on peut
emprunter c'est une c'est tout à fait
légitime et deuxièmement je pense que la
banque centrale européenne devrait y
contribuer voilà c'est ce qu'on voulait
pas continuer comme ça il ya aussi une
loi qui a été remis sur le haut du
panier c'est celle sur le droit de vote
des étrangers aux élections locales qui
sera visiblement déconnecté des
élections municipales
qu'est ce que vous en pensez après
l'état déconnecté des suivantes
élections municipales sais pas
j'en pense le plus grand mal là je pense
que la nationale la citoyenneté le droit
de vote
c'est lié à la nationalité là c'est une
promesse de campagne il respecte ses
promesses et respecte ses promesses à
proust c'est très bien mais nous sommes
pas obligés de voter pour les trois
cinquièmes de la salle du parlement sont
pas obligés de voter pour lui s'il fait
un référendum le français sont pas
obligés de voter pour
voyez les promesses et les foires après
il faut les traduire fausse traduire en
actes en loi voilà c'est une promeneuse
ça n'est qu'une promesse
les parlementaires socialistes étaient
chaudement conviés à la maison de
l'amérique latine pour écouter le
président françois hollande qui est venu
leur parler après sa conférence de
presse entretien d'une demi heure
environ pour tenter de regonfler une
majorité parfois grognon ça semble avoir
plutôt marché voici des réactions à la
sortie
nous n'avons pas besoin de le rencontrer
régulièrement en tout cas toutes les
semaines mais qu'ils viennent de temps
en temps dire aux parlementaires merci
pour ce que vous faites et j'ai besoin
de vous ne lâchez rien se tait nous a
dit aujourd'hui était important que moi
je veux pouvoir discuter
je suis pour la réussite de ce
quinquennat et pour la réussite de
françois hollande moi j'ai moins de
pudeur que lui je veux qu'il soit réélu
en 2017 c'est clair et pour ça et bien
il faut qu'il entende tout ce qui
s'exprime dans le pays et tout ce qui
s'exprime au sein de la gauche
alors françois hollande président lui
président n'inviterait jamais les
parlementaires à l'elysée donc c'est lui
qui se déplacent chaque fois que c'est
une c'est un détail c'est il nous
expliquait que deux présents pouvaient
pas recevoir des parlementaires de sa
majorité et maintenant il va les voir
c'est franchement on est on est dans
dans l'apparence il fait exactement ce
qu'a fait nicolas sarkozy parce qu'avec
le quinquennat est bien le président de
la république
on peut le regretter mais obligés de
négocier tout le temps avec sa majorité
donc voilà il l'a fait là encore ce
qu'il avait dit qui au fond ne ferai
jamais dire être le présent qui
rassemble qui le chef d'une majorité il
est le chef d'une majorité tout en tout
en étant le président de tous les
français
alors il arrive mieux à mon avis en soit
être chef d'une majorité que le
président de tous les français
henri guaino pour finir de démission je
vais vous emmener au cinéma je vous
emmène voir un film marquer peut-être
que vous connaissez un petit peu déjà
toute l'histoire de ce crime ce qu il
avait été conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
à l'elysée ce film s'appelle le pouvoir
vous pouvez le voir en ce moment sur vos
écrans
portes ouvertes à l'elysée pour la
première année du quinquennat de
françois hollande
simon barbarie a vu le film voilà ce qui
leur hausse
quand françois hollande fait son cinéma
c'est patrick rotman qui tient la caméra
cette semaine sort dans les salles le
documentaire le pouvoir pendant un an le
réalisateur a suivi le président dans
son quotidien
objectif montrer au grand public ce
qu'est véritablement l'exercice du
pouvoir
je ne me suis pas mis dans un rôle
j'assume une fonction je ne joue pas un
rôle je suis pleinement président co
écrit avec le journaliste pierre favier
le regard des auteurs et contemplatif
plans longs sur les dorures du palais
salons feutrés où la parole est basse et
les huissiers méticuleux l'elysée prend
alors des allures de tour d'ivoire comme
une illustration de l'isolément du
pouvoir patrick rotman assure n'avoir eu
aucune contrainte imposée par françois
hollande
l'impression dominante est pourtant
celle de la frustration comme si la
caméra se retirait au moment où les
discussions deviennent intéressantes et
où le vrai pouvoir s'exerce ne laissant
ainsi aux spectateurs que l'anecdotique
la manne dans les discos qui vont
arriver faut pas que ce soit un
brouillon on n'a pas le temps de faire
du brouillon il faut commander des
enfants pour écrire directement au
propre donc vous bien serré le fait que
ça ainsi discours nous
patient aimable blagueur françois
hollande eux se montre tel qu'on le
connaît mais le trop plein
d'illustrations du palais présidentiel
nous fait amèrement constaté que le
véritable acteur de ce documentaire ce
n'est pas lui mais bien l'elysée henri
guaino est il vrai qu'à l'elysée on vit
en vase clos et qu'on est un peu enfermé
c'est le cas visiblement quand on voit
ce quand on voit ce film c'est nos
sentiments quand on a en tout cas
donc c'était le sentiment voulait donner
aussi le réalisateur bon jeu
non moi j'ai pas eu l'impression de
vivre en vase clos pas tu touches c'est
un endroit où tout remonte tout les
pulsations duper toutes les réclamations
toutes les protestations toutes les
aspirations
selon lui aura été très très actif sa
patte et toujours le cas dans le passé
mais en tout cas ce nicolas services it
est très actif en oubliant là où l'on
procédait trône omniprésident mais je
concède que maintenant tout rond tout
remonte aussi ça c'est le quinquennat
aussi qui a rendu qui a changé la nature
de de l'elysée voir ce film ou pas oui
j'irai le voir parce que ce sont des
lieux qui me sont familiers mais non je
suis pas con absolument convaincu que
président de la république doivent jouer
dans ce genre de dans ce genre de film
on voit bien c'est rien n'est naturel
puisque le vrai exercice du pouvoir est
caché un steak haché pour le reste mais
on joue donc il joue son propre rôle il
fait l'acteur est ce que c'est bien ce
que c'est bien ça sa mission offrir
directement au propre digne et françois
hollande vous la plume de nicolas
sarkozy faisait beaucoup de brouillon
vous écrivez moi je fais beaucoup de
brouillon je pense que la qualité de
certains disques au président c'est
aujourd'hui amènerait peut-être à
s'interroger sur la nécessité de faire
quelques brouillon et bah écoutez c'est
sûr c'est gentiment que nous allons nous
séparer mais tellement bon merci d'avoir
été avec nous tout au long de cette
émission et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine merci et bonne semaine à tous
bon week end